- So, the Senate failed
to procure enough votes
to convict Former President Trump
of the charge of
incitement to insurrection
and thus, in a way, the Senate
has acquitted President Trump
of his record second impeachment.
For many, this was a fait accompli,
that there was simply
no way it was possible
for the Democrats or anyone else
to convince enough Republicans
to form the necessary 2/3 majority
in order to convict on impeachment.
But even still this
was a marked difference
from the first impeachment trial
and a record number of members
of the same party as the former president
voted to convict.
But let's take a look at the five days
that comprise the impeachment trial,
examine the legal arguments,
and see if this was indeed inevitable
and whether the arguments
on the prosecution side
and the defense side
held any water.
(bright music)
Hey, LegalEagles, it's time to think
like an impeachment lawyer,
because Former President Trump
was able to escape
conviction on impeachment
for a record second time,
but this time only narrowly.
Now, as we've talked about
many times on this channel,
an impeachment trial is
not a criminal trial.
You know this.
You know that it is a political trial,
or more specifically it's
a trial by Parliament.
And lawyers like myself
like to make analogies
to the criminal justice system,
but these analogies are always imperfect,
and this moves in several
different directions.
So we're gonna be talking
about things like due process
and the hearsay rule,
but often these things
are completely inchoate
in an impeachment setting
because the Senate makes its own rules.
It can adopt to the
federal rules of evidence
but it doesn't have to,
and due process considerations
that exist for private citizens
in the criminal justice system
simply do not exist in
an impeachment setting.
But that doesn't necessarily mean
that we need to throw any of that out,
it just means that it might
not necessarily carry the day.
And we saw this throughout
the impeachment trial
with lawyers making
contradictory arguments,
with senators justifying their reasons
for voting or not voting for
conviction of impeachment
in ways that absolutely do not jive
with the criminal justice system.
And we also saw things
like a group of senators
meeting with the defense lawyers.
We saw Senators Cruz, Graham, and Lee
actually meet with
President Trump's surrogates
to discuss the defense of the President.
And people were absolutely
right to point out
that in a criminal justice setting
members of the jury
meeting and strategizing
with attorneys for either side
would be completely improper.
This is not a criminal justice setting.
Literally the impeachment
clause of the Constitution
does not allow for criminal penalties.
It's on a narrow issue
of preventing someone
from holding office again.
So, look, politicians are
going to be politicians.
But that being said, let's
dive into the legal arguments
that were made.
So let's start with the very first
foundational jurisdictional question,
whether the Senate can even
hold an impeachment hearing
related to an official who is
no longer in that position.
The first day of the impeachment trial
was devoted to this very question,
because generally you have
to determine issues of law
before you can get to the issues of fact.
Some argued that the Constitution
doesn't answer this question directly,
so let's start with the historical context
that the Framers were dealing with.
- 'Cause as Hamilton wrote,
"England provided the model
"from which the idea of this
institution has been borrowed."
- In fact, every impeachment that occurred
during the Framers' lifetime
actually concerned a former official.
And the consensus of the first states
to draft their own constitutions
was that impeachment of former
officials was not banned.
- Every single state
constitution in the 1780s
either specifically said
that former officials
could be impeached
or were entirely consistent with the idea.
In contrast, not a
single state constitution
prohibited trials of former officials.
- And Virginia, Delaware,
Vermont, and Pennsylvania
explicitly permitted late impeachment
in their state constitutions,
which were written before
the US Constitution.
And, generally speaking, in
the pre-constitutional era,
officers were impeached
after they left office.
In Vermont, for example,
State Representative Jonathan Fassett
was impeached after he joined an angry mob
that wanted to stop a
county court from convening.
Huh, I wonder if that sounds familiar.
He was impeached and later
convicted after he left office.
And the Constitution was being hashed out
during the same month
that British Governor-General
of India William Hastings
was being impeached for corruption.
Hastings was already out
of office at the time.
The people who drafted the Constitution
repeatedly referred to
the Hastings impeachment
in an offhand manner,
the same way that people in our era
may refer to the Clinton impeachment
without getting into the gritty details.
And apparently the Founders did not object
to the lateness of this impeachment.
Instead, they used it to show
why impeachment was important.
George Mason noted that Hastings
committed a slew of crimes
but none of them fit the
definition of treason.
Mason warned that the
definition of treason
in the US Constitution
would not include attempts to
"subvert the Constitution."
Therefore, impeachment should include
high crimes and misdemeanors.
And George Mason certainly imagined
someone like Donald Trump.
In other words,
Mason thought that making
a character judgment
was an important part of the
scheme of checks and balances
between the branches of government.
So, Lin-Manuel, where is
George Mason's musical?
So, not surprisingly,
almost the entire first day
of the impeachment trial
was devoted to this legal question.
Can the Senate hold an impeachment trial
related to an official
who has either resigned
or whose term has expired?
And generally that's a good idea
because if this was a criminal trial
you would almost always dispose
of all the legal questions
before getting to the issues of fact.
And that's especially important here
because this is a political question
where the Supreme Court
would never touch it
with a 10-foot pole.
In other words,
even if Former President
Trump was convicted,
there's no way that he
could try to appeal this
to the federal courts
and say that this was
improper or unconstitutional.
The Supreme Court would
100% never answer it
because this is a political question
that's left up to the judicial branch.
And, so, given that on the
first day the Senate held a vote
and held by a majority
that the Senate believed
it had jurisdiction to hold
this impeachment trial,
one would think that this
legal question was settled.
But of course this is
partially a political question
and thus the senators
can do whatever they want
for basically whatever reasons they want.
But there is I think one important analogy
to the criminal justice system
that applies in a situation like this,
because the way that a
criminal trial would work
is that the lawyers and the judge
would hash out all of the legal issues
and eventually, once those
things are hashed out,
the judge will give the jury
instructions to the jury
that gives them all of
the law that they need
to understand the decision
that they're going to make.
And there's a phrase that we
use to describe what happens
when a jury disregards
those kind of instructions
and makes a decision based on
whatever rational they want,
and that phrase is jury nullification.
And it's completely reasonable to say
that several members of the Senate
engaged in jury nullification
to find Former President Trump not guilty.
And then there's also the
doctrine of unclean hands
because it's not like
the date of this trial
was set in stone from on high.
Let's not forget that former
Senate majority leader
Mitch McConnell was in control
of the Senate's schedule
and prevented the Senate
from holding a trial
on Former President Trump
while he was still in office.
And that's particularly galling
when Mitch McConnell used that timing
as the reason that he
didn't vote to convict,
saying that impeachment is
primarily a tool for removal,
though he leaves open the argument
that impeachment can be used
outside of that context,
which the majority of legal
scholars believe as well.
And some have argued,
again analogizing to the
criminal justice system,
that if you in fact believe
that the Senate doesn't have jurisdiction,
then you can't participate in that vote.
But there is one senator
who I think threaded this needle
and actually came to a principled stance
while fundamentally disagreeing
with some of these
jurisdictional questions,
and that's Senator Richard
Burr from North Carolina
who recognized that he couldn't hide
behind the unconstitutionality argument
and voted to convict.
He stated, "When this process started,
"I believed that it was unconstitutional
"to impeach a president who
was no longer in office.
"I still believe that to be the case.
"However, the Senate is an
institution based on precedent,
"and given that the majority of the Senate
"voted to proceed with this trial,
"the question of constitutionality
"is now established precedent.
"As an impartial juror,
"my role is now to determine
"whether House managers have
sufficiently made the case
"for the article of impeachment
against President Trump.
"I've listened to the arguments
presented by both sides
"and considered the facts.
"The facts are clear."
And then voted for conviction.
Those are the words of someone
who had a reasonable argument
related to the process
of the impeachment trial
but then did his duty
based on his position
as the impeachment went forward.
So, with that historical context,
let's look at the actual
text of the Constitution.
Article II, Section 4 says,
"The president, vice president,
"and all civil officers
of the United States
"shall be removed from
office on impeachment
"for and conviction of treason, bribery,
"or other high crimes and misdemeanors."
Trump argues that the plain
meaning of the word officer
means a person who currently holds office,
not an ex-officer.
The phrase "removed from
office" in this context
would mean that once a
person was already gone,
he or she cannot be removed.
And Trump lawyer David Schoen
addressed this argument
in his trial brief
but didn't discuss it in any detail
during his opening statement.
The Democrats argued that the question
of whether a former official can be tried
as part of the impeachment process
depends not just on the language
of Article II, Section 4,
but also depends on other
sections of the Constitution
that deal with impeachment.
They begin with the question,
how does the Constitution
describe the accused
in an impeachment trial?
We already know that Article
II, Section 4 simply says
the president, vice president,
and all civil officers
can be removed.
Trump's lawyers rely
exclusively on this provision
to make their argument
that only current officers
can be impeached.
And House managers rely on Chuck Cooper,
a staunchly conservative lawyer
who has represented Republicans
including Minority Leader Mark Meadows.
- As Cooper says,
Article II, Section 4
means just what it says.
The first half describes
what an official must do to be impeached,
namely commit high
crimes and misdemeanors,
and the second half describes
what happens when civil
officers of the United States,
including the sitting president,
are convicted.
Removal from office.
That's it.
- In Cooper's words,
that establishes what is
known in the criminal law
as a mandatory minimum punishment.
And then we move on to the next section.
To define the identity of the accused
in an impeachment trial,
the House managers also rely
on Article I, Section 3, Clause 6 and 7,
which refer to a person and a party
rather than a president, vice
president, or civil officer.
Clause 6, "The Senate
shall have the sole power
"to try all impeachments.
"When sitting for that purpose,
"they shall be on oath or affirmation.
"When the President of the
United States is tried,
"the Chief Justice shall preside.
"And no person shall be convicted
"without the concurrence of
2/3 of the members present."
Then we move on to Clause 7.
"Judgment in cases of impeachment
"shall not extend further
than removal from office
"and the disqualification
to hold enjoyment
"of any office of honor, trust, or profit
"under the United States.
"But the party convicted
shall nevertheless be liable
"and subject to indictment,
trial, and punishment
"according to law."
So here we have the words person and party
rather than a civil officer
in describing the accused.
Arguably, this word choice
includes former officials.
- Who could be put on trial,
rather, for impeachment
other than civil officers?
Who else could a person or a party be?
Well, really, there's
only one possible answer.
Former officers.
- And then circling back
to some prior language that we read,
the House managers also
direct our attention
back to the language of
Article I, Section 3,
which states judgment
in cases of impeachment
shall not extend further
than to removal from office
and disqualification.
Representative Joe
Neguse gave a masterclass
in the construction of these words.
- [Joe] The Constitution does not say,
"Removal from office and
then disqualification."
It doesn't say,
"Removal from office followed
by disqualification."
- Now, on the other hand,
the Trump argument is that the and binds
both the removal and
disqualification together
and thus you can't have a removal
of someone who's already
been removed from office,
meaning that therefore you
can't have the disqualification
against someone who's already
been removed from office.
The vast majority of legal scholars
do not adhere to this
particular interpretation
and are following what
Representative Neguse
was already arguing.
But then we go back to
Article I, Section 3,
which states that "the Senate
shall have the sole power
"to try all impeachments."
The House managers argue
that all means all.
It doesn't say the Senate has the power
to try impeachments
against sitting officers.
What we're left with is
an impeachment mechanism
that includes four possible punishments.
Impeachment by the House,
removal from office by the Senate,
disqualification from
holding office again,
and a criminal prosecution
in a court of law.
And, of course, many have
argued the policy argument
that a disqualification was
subject to a time limit.
That creates a dangerous loophole,
a potential January exception.
- Officials could commit
the most extraordinary
destructive offenses
against the American people,
high crimes and misdemeanors,
and they'd have total control
over whether they can ever be impeached,
and, if they are,
whether the Senate can try the case.
If they want to escape any public inquiry
into their misconduct
or the risk of disqualification
from future office,
then it's pretty simple.
They could just resign
one minute before the House impeaches,
or even one minute
before the Senate trial,
or they could resign
during the Senate trial
if it's not looking so well.
That would effectively
erase disqualification
from the Constitution.
- So, assuming that this
impeachment trial is legitimate,
which the overwhelming
weight of legal authority
seems to suggest,
that takes us to the arguments
for the conviction on impeachment
and the arguments against.
On days two and three of
the impeachment trial,
House managers made their
case arguing for conviction.
House managers spent most of day two
presenting new footage
of the riots themselves.
And, honestly, it's shocking.
And let's take a moment to recognize
a true American hero, Eugene Goodman,
who appears to have single-handedly
saved the life of Mitt Romney
and countless other
representatives and senators.
A man whose quick thinking saved lives
and whose decision not to use his gun
also spared the lives
of countless rioters.
And we forget that this
easily could have been
a massacre in two different directions.
Not only the politicians,
but also the rioters and
protestors themselves.
And while many would have cheered that on,
that too would have been
an American tragedy.
And it's only through the quick thinking
of people like Eugene Goodman
that that tragedy was averted.
So let's start with the
arguments of the House managers.
In their trial brief they argue
that "this trial arises from
President Donald J. Trump's
"incitement of insurrection
"against the Republic
he swore to protect."
The House impeachment managers
walk through the lead-up to January 6th,
discussing how the Trump change campaign
refused to conceded that
Trump lost the election.
Even after Trump lost over 60 legal cases
related to the election,
he refused to accept the loss
and instead saying he won in a landslide
and the vote was stolen from him.
Former President Trump also pressured
state election officials,
state representatives,
governors and US attorneys
to overturn the will of
the people in their states.
After the Electoral College voted
to certify President Biden's win,
Former President Trump
asked his supporters
to come to Washington on
January 6th to "stop the steal."
January 6th was the day
that Congress would meet
to certify the election,
and Trump told his supporters
that the results could
be changed on that day.
Trump spent approximately $50 million
on a campaign to stop the steal.
- These ads were designed to run
all the way up to January 5.
And then they stopped.
- Leading many to suspect
that the Trump campaign
didn't actually think
that there was any value
in making the arguments after the 6th
and putting everything into that date.
The Trump campaign helped
plan the event on January 6th.
Trump selected the date
because this was the day
that Biden's win would be finalized.
- The Constitution says you
have to protect our country
and you have to protect our Constitution
and you can't vote on fraud.
And fraud breaks up
everything, doesn't it?
When you catch somebody in a fraud,
you're allowed to go by
very different rules.
So I hope Mike has the courage
to do what he has to do.
- He's talking about you!
(people shouting)
- And we fight.
We fight like hell.
And if you don't fight like hell,
you're not gonna have a country anymore.
- Trump told them that Mike Pence
could overturn the election results.
Right after Trump was informed
that Vice President
Pence had been evacuated
due to all of the supporters
invading the Capitol,
minutes later he tweeted to the
mob that Pence was a coward.
"Mike Pence didn't have the courage
"to do what should have been done
"to protect our country
and our Constitution.
"USA demands the truth."
The mob yelled Trump's
tweet into a bullhorn
while they went into the Capitol building.
The mob searched for Pence,
the mob searched for the votes,
and the mob searched for
other elected representatives
who were going through with
the election certification.
And as demonstrated by his calls
to Senators Tuberville and Lee,
Trump was willing to use the violence
to his effective advantage,
as leverage to try and
get them to do something
to stop the certification.
So this is the factual basis
for the articles of
impeachment from the House.
Now let's talk about the legal basis.
The House argues that these actions
were high crimes and misdemeanors.
I've done many other videos
on the meaning of high
crimes and misdemeanors,
but suffice to say almost
all legal scholars agree
that the term was meant
to include transgressions
that were not necessarily actual crimes
prohibited by federal law
since there wasn't very much
federal law at the time,
and that it was a catchall for things
that are a violation of public trust.
Certainly actual crimes
could be high crimes and
misdemeanors as well,
but it's not necessary
that a president be removed
because of an actual statutory crime.
And as we've discussed,
the Founders believed that
the actions against the state
which subvert the
government were impeachable,
as Alexander Hamilton described them
as actions which are "political,
"as they relate chiefly to
injuries done immediately
"to society itself."
Historically, politicians
have taken the position
that these offenses could be even moral,
such as having an affair
and then lying under oath
to cover it up.
The House Democrats write
that "if provoking an insurrection riot
"against a Joint Session Congress
"after losing an election
"is not an impeachable offense,
"it's hard to image what would be."
The House argues that Trump
attacks the foundations
of the democratic process itself.
"Under absolutely no
circumstance may a candidate
"for any position at
any level of government
"respond to electoral defeat
by provoking armed violence."
And the House managers,
anticipating the arguments
of Trump's defense
that he had a First Amendment right
to say whatever he wanted
whenever he wanted,
the House managers have
two counterarguments
that the First Amendment is not a defense
to the actions and
statements that were made
on January 6th and the
lead-up to January 6th.
First they say that President
Trump should be held
to a higher standard of
conduct than a private citizen.
"No one would seriously suggest
"that a president should be
immunized from impeachment
"if he publicly championed the adoption
"of a totalitarian government,
"swore an oath of eternal
loyalty to a foreign power,
"or advocated that states secede from
"and overthrow the Union,
"even though private
citizens could be protected
"by the First Amendment for such speech."
The House managers argue that interfering
with the peaceful transfer
of power with violence
is an assault on core
First Amendment principles.
And the House's second argument
is that there's already quite a bit
of First Amendment jurisprudence
on the limits of some speech.
That speech is not protected where it is
"directed to inciting or
producing imminent lawless action
"and is likely to incite
or produce such action."
I've already covered whether
Former President Trump's speech
incited the riot in another video
from a criminal law perspective,
and there's certainly
arguments on either side,
but the impeachment is not about
whether Former President Trump
violated a criminal statute
and is going to jail.
The impeachment trial
literally cannot result
in a jail conviction.
It says specifically in the Constitution
that that is not allowed.
It's about whether his conduct
as a whole was so serious
that America should send a
message to future presidents
and to insurrectionists
in whether it should punish the speech
that was actually made
by preventing such a transgressor
from being able to hold office again.
And that takes us to the third argument
of the Democratic House managers
which is, again, anticipating
arguments from the Trump camp.
They argue that late impeachments
are absolutely constitutional.
The House cites the same authorities
that we talked about earlier in this video
in talking about how late impeachments
are both constitutional and
have a fairly long history,
and they also rely on old writings
of Professor Jonathan Turley,
one of Trump's chief defenders.
Turley wrote several journal articles
that impeaching ex-presidents
is constitutional.
- [Man] Professor Turley argued
that the House could have impeached
and the Senate could
have tried Richard Nixon
after he resigned.
"Future presidents could not assume
"that mere resignation would
avoid a trial of their conduct
"in the United States Senate.
"No man in no circumstance
can escape the account
"which he owes to the
laws of his country."
- Of course, it's also
important to point out
that President Trump was not
impeached after he left office.
He was impeached when he was in office
and now it's up to the Senate to try.
And, in fact, as many have pointed out,
Mitch McConnell could
have allowed the Senate
to conduct the trial
before Former President Trump left office.
But this is not a case of
the impeachment happening
after the resignation or after
the official has left office,
the impeachment, the indictment
phase already happened
while Trump was president.
Of course, Turley has been
featured heavily on Fox News
arguing the exact opposite
of his earlier views
without saying why and how
his hundreds of pages of
arguments are now false.
But Jonathan Turley is
going to Jonathan Turley.
- What they're citing is an
article from 21 years ago.
- And the House managers' arguments
are also sound in classic
penological theory,
one point arguing-
- It's making sure that
no future official,
no future president does
the same exact thing
President Trump does.
- What they're arguing
is in fact deterrence,
both individual and general.
They want to make sure that
Former President Trump himself
never has an opportunity to
do the things that he did,
as well as making sure that no one
like Former President Trump
does it in the future as well,
as well as the common
justification of punitive measures,
punishing Former President Trump
for the actions that he did undertake.
Those are the classic reasons
as to why you would
incarcerate someone in jail
in the first place.
So that takes us to Former
President Trump's arguments.
The House impeachment
managers cite Trump's actions
and words and conduct
from before, during, and after the riot.
Trump, on the other hand,
has chosen to focus on narrow issues
of whether his January 6th
speech would have made him liable
for the actual crime
of incitement of imminent lawless action.
Trump camp argues that President Trump
did not commit the crime of incitement
and focus on the text of
the January 6th speech.
Trump argued in his brief,
"Words do matter
"and the words of President
Trump's January 6th speech
"speak for themselves.
"Of the over 10,000 words spoken,
"Mr. Trump used the word fight
"a little more than a handful of times
"and each time in a figurative sense
"that has long been
accepted in public discourse
"when urging people to
stand and use their voices
"to be heard on matters important."
As the Trump camp points out,
the former president
spoke for about an hour
but never advocated for violence
or told anyone to get their weapons.
Although he told them to
head over to the Capitol,
he did not go with them
nor did he tell them
to storm the building.
And the Trump camp is focused on language
that doesn't fit the
House managers' narrative,
focusing on statements like,
"I know that everyone
here will soon be marching
"over to the Capitol building
"to peacefully and patriotically
make your voices heard."
And the next big argument
that the Trump camp makes
is that the Senate simply
doesn't have jurisdiction
over a former public official,
citing the constitutional
text we referred to earlier.
Former President Trump's
lawyers spent most of day four
laying out their defense as it was.
And by the way, I'm not
particularly impressed
by Trump's legal defense team here.
With respect to Bruce Castor,
he legitimately seemed to be confused
at many different times.
It seems like he winged everything,
and often when it was clear
he was not talking from his notes,
he would go back to his notes,
and sometimes things that he
had written out ahead of time
were worse than the things
he was just talking about
off the cuff.
- You know, it's interesting because
I don't wanna steal the
thunder from the other lawyers,
but Nebraska you're going to hear
is quite a judicial thinking place.
- With respect to David Schoen,
he seemed to think that
the louder he yelled
the more persuasive he was,
and he was very wrong about that.
And then there's Michael Van Der Veen
who is a personal injury lawyer
who absolutely looked and sounded
like a personal injury lawyer
who had absolutely no understanding
of the grand stakes that he was on.
- These depositions
should be done in person,
in my office, in Philadelphia.
- This was a B team of lawyers
filling in for Former President Trump
after his first legal team quit en mass,
and it absolutely showed.
And many times the Trump team argued
that Former President Trump
was not afforded due process
and therefore the whole thing
should just be thrown out.
This argument I find particularly galling
because on the one hand they're saying
that investigations should be done,
depositions should be taken,
and at the exact same
time they're also arguing
that the whole thing should be thrown out
because too much time was taken,
too much time has passed,
and now Trump is no longer in office
and thus there's no jurisdiction
for this impeachment at all.
And yes, lawyers argue in
the alternative all the time,
but that doesn't mean
that that's a persuasive tactic to take.
And here, as we've
talked about many times,
the requirements for a criminal conviction
simply don't apply here.
The beyond reasonably doubt standard
does not apply in impeachments.
And there's a lot of confusion
about the term incitement itself.
Incitement means a lot
of different things.
It is, number one, a crime
under most jurisdictions.
It's also an exception
to the First Amendment
in terms of speech that is not protected
by the First Amendment.
It is a political offense
as to something that the Senate might feel
is unbecoming of the president himself
and thus warrants removal
or being barred from public office.
And it's also being
used as just a shorthand
for everything that happened.
And because you have these
different definitions
going across purposes,
a lot of the different arguments
are like ships passing in the night.
And it's all bound up in this question
of whether the president should
be held to a higher standard
than your average citizen
or a lower one.
And remember, the vast
majority of legal weight
says that the president
doesn't have to be guilty
of an actual crime
to be impeached, removed,
and barred from office.
And playing off of that confusion,
the Trump lawyers created a video montage
of Democrats using the
term fight in context
that don't rise to the
level of incitement.
Of course, many people argued the counter
that of course it depends on the context,
that it also depends on the intent.
None of these Democratic
members of Congress
ever had the intention to
actually incite violence,
that the violence was not incited,
no riot ever came about of these words,
and that the context was
incredibly different.
But the point is valid
that different words
can mean different things
in different contexts,
but it really feels like these arguments
were a false equivalence
and a lot of what aboutism.
And apart from the due process arguments,
the Trump lawyers argued
extensively about hearsay,
and this makes me want
to pull out my own hair
for several different reasons.
First of all, as we've talked
about many different times,
the Senate can use
whatever standard it wants,
and generally it has almost
always allowed hearsay
as evidence in impeachment trials.
But more to the point,
almost all of the hearsay
statements at issue here
would be admissible in trial
because they weren't being used
for the truth of the matter asserted,
which is necessary for hearsay.
But rather, they were being used
for the state of mind of
Former President Trump
and his intent,
which is a non-hearsay purpose
to the statements themselves.
So yes, they were out-of-court statements,
but not all out-of-court
statements are inadmissible,
and the vast majority of the
things being discussed here
would probably have been admissible.
And putting apart the fact
that almost all of the senators
who are participating
in this particular trial
were firsthand witnesses
and the hearsay wasn't really necessary
for them to make their decisions
because they were a part in person
to witnessing all of this stuff.
But perhaps the biggest
irony is that the defense
extensively used hearsay themselves.
The entire defense case,
because President Trump wasn't
willing to testify himself,
relied on out-of-court statements.
So if you're going to exclude
a whole bunch of the prosecution's case
on the basis they're
out-of-court statements,
then you have to disregard
the entire defense case.
Now there was big news
after the fourth day
of the impeachment trial
when Representative Herrera
Beutler, a Republican,
came forward and relayed
part of the conversation that she had
with Representative Kevin
McCarthy of California.
This conversation seemed to dispute
basically everything the defense had said
about Former President Trump's knowledge
about what was going on at the time.
- In the middle of the insurrection,
when House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
called the President to beg for help,
President Trump responded, and I quote,
"Well, Kevin, I guess these people
"are more upset about the
election than you are."
- Now if this were a court case
it is possible to get double hearsay
or hearsay within
hearsay to be admissible,
you just need an exception for
both layers of the hearsay.
And arguably that's met,
because between Trump and McCarthy
that would go to President
Trump's state of mind,
and as between McCarthy
and Herrera Beutler
that could be a present sense impression
or excited utterance.
Based on the circumstances,
there would be an exception
to the hearsay rule
and arguably that statement
would be admissible in court.
And that takes us to the third argument
that the Trump lawyers make,
which is that an impeachment
of a private citizen
is really a bill of attainder.
Now this is an argument that probably made
a lot of first-year law
students extremely happy,
because bills of attainder
don't come up that often.
But Trump argues that the
impeachment trial by the Senate
of a private citizen
violates Article I, Section
9 of the US Constitution
which states that "no bill of
attainder shall be passed."
What is a bill of attainder?
Well, that is basically
a prohibition on Congress
from enacting any law that
legislatively determines guilt
and inflicts punishment upon
an identifiable individual
without provisions of the
protections of a judicial trial.
Now according to Trump,
this impeachment and every impeachment
is a bill of attainder
because it allows the legislature
to make a finding of guilt.
A bill of attainder is the
kind of legislative act
that only has effect when it's adopted
by both houses of Congress
and signed into law by the president.
Impeachment and removal,
by contrast, though,
can be accomplished by Congress alone,
and most importantly it's written
into the text of the Constitution.
So if a bill of attainder were to nullify
the impeachment clause,
that would be a big problem,
and there's no interpretation
of the Constitution
where that can possibly be correct.
And this means that Trump is
legally incorrect in saying
that a conviction of the Senate
counts as a bill of attainder.
The Senate isn't voting on any such bill,
it's putting Former
President Trump on trial
for impeachment, which is part
of the Constitution itself.
The President Joe Biden doesn't
have a role in impeachment.
And there've been all kind
of bad faith arguments
about saying that you
can't deprive someone
of life liberty or property
without due process,
but the due process is the
impeachment trial itself.
And on top of that,
this is not a depravation
of the normal Fourth Amendment rights.
It's written into the Constitution
that you can have an impeachment
that has the punishment
of preventing someone
from being able to hold office again.
It's written into the Constitution itself.
But this distinction
between a bill of attainder
and an impeachment
goes back far into English common law.
Under the law, English
monarchs would have to sign off
on any bills of attainder.
And impeachment was added as a tool
precisely because it did
not need royal consent,
it gave Parliament the
ability to constrain
the executive power.
And the American Founders were not fond
of bills of attainder
because they effectively
allowed the government
to a make a post-hoc decision
about punishing someone criminally
as an individual private citizen.
But they really liked impeachment
because they feared a monarch
coming to the American executive.
This was the whole reason for
the Revolution to begin with,
that they wanted to
cast aside the monarchy.
So this takes us to
one of the main thrusts
of the Trump lawyers,
which is that the First
Amendment prohibits
impeachment for words.
Trump argues that the
impeachment invites senators
to violate the First Amendment principle
of freedom of speech.
And Trump says that impeachment itself
is always constrained by free speech.
"The Constitution must, at a minimum,
"serve as a limitation on
the ability of Congress
"to impeach for high
crimes and misdemeanors."
Here, Trump is essentially
saying that the government,
i.e. the House of Representatives,
is trampling on his free speech rights
by impeaching him for
things that he said and did.
And the crux of this argument
is that Congress cannot impeach a person
for constitutional conduct.
And if we tried to apply
this principle consistently,
then other articles of impeachment
against other presidents
would also have to be rejected.
Bill Clinton arguably had
a Fourth and Fourteenth
Amendment privacy right
to consensual sexual
conduct with another adult
and a First Amendment
right to lie about it.
But the problem is there's
all kinds of legally
and morally impermissible acts
that are based solely in speech.
Defamation is a solely speech-based act.
For the most part,
bribery tends to be a speech-based act.
When you're making a bargain
with an elected official
for their own pecuniary interests,
that's based in speech.
And there's basically no argument
that some of these things
wouldn't give rise to impeachment.
And the Trump lawyers are trying to blend
legal and political arguments together.
The Trump lawyers accused
the House managers
of creating an impeachment process
that yields to the "unbridled
whims of House managers."
But a bipartisan group of
legislators in the House
believed that Trump's conduct
and words were impeachable.
Trump argues that they were all motivated
by Trump derangement syndrome,
but this isn't really a legal argument,
it's a political one,
and it's one that of
course he's free to make
but it doesn't seem to hold
water on a legal basis.
The House of course argues
that it didn't impeach President Trump
because he expressed an
unpopular political opinion,
but rather it impeached him
because he was willfully
inciting a violent insurrection
against the government.
They argued, "We live in a nation
"governed by the rule of law,
"not mob violence incited by presidents
"who cannot accept their
own electoral defeat."
And of course President Trump argues
that he did not commit a violation of law.
Trump argues the same
position in this impeachment
that he did the first time around,
that a president can only be impeached
if he violates a criminal statute.
The Trump lawyers argue that
the only relevant inquiry
is whether Trump's January 6th speech
incited people to imminent lawless action,
and to determine whether it did
we should not consider
the broader environment
in which this speech was actually made,
we should only look narrowly
at the actual text itself.
And on the fifth day of
the impeachment trial,
the big drama came as a result
of the Democrats winning a vote
to be able to call witnesses at the trial
but then backing down,
accepting an stipulation of
the Herrera Beutler statement,
and then moving forward
with closing arguments.
Now, personally, I would have
liked to have seen witnesses.
I think that it would have been
good for historical reasons
to lay even more of a factual foundation
for everything that went on
and to be able to force
some of the testimony
related to things that
Former President Trump
may or may not have been thinking
and when he was thinking them.
But at the same time it's
probably not the case
that witnesses would have
actually changed the result
of this impeachment trial.
And at the end of the day
57 senators voted to convict
Former President Trump,
which was not enough for the 2/3 majority
needed for conviction.
And the number is a record.
There were seven Republican senators
who voted to convict Trump,
and that is seven times greater
than the previous number of senators
who voted to convict a
president of their own party,
which that number was set
by Senator Mitt Romney
just a year ago in President Trump's
first impeachment trial.
So the question is, what happens next?
I suspect that there will
probably be commissions,
subpoenas, investigations,
and criminal prosecutions.
Remember, the impeachment
punishment is extremely narrow.
It's simply removal from office
and being barred from running again.
Theoretically, impeachment itself is dead.
If under these circumstances
the president cannot be impeached,
then it doesn't seem like
there is any realistic scenario
where any president
will ever be impeached,
which in itself is I
think a worrying trend.
And even though Mitch McConnell voted
to acquit President Trump,
he still recognizes that Trump is liable
for everything that he did in office
and seems to be almost asking prosecutors
to criminally prosecute
Former President Trump.
- They did this because they'd
been fed wild falsehoods
by the most powerful man on Earth.
- And bad news for those
that want to invoke the
Fourteenth Amendment
to bar people who have participated
in sedition against the United States
from holding office.
The 57 Senate votes that were secured
to convict President Trump on impeachment
are not enough votes for cloture,
so given that the filibuster still exists,
there's not going to be enough votes
to actually bar him under
the Fourteenth Amendment,
assuming that the votes stay the same.
But there is some good news.
Given that this was
truly a bipartisan effort
with both members of the House
and seven Republican senators
who voted for conviction,
this is probably a green light
for criminal prosecutions.
Normally you would assume
that state district attorneys
or the US Attorney General
would be extremely reluctant
to engage in a criminal
investigation of a former president.
But given the overwhelming
bipartisan support,
it sort of signals to those
law enforcement officers
that you can proceed if there is indeed
a true criminal violation
by Former President Trump.
And there's also more good news
in that the threat of impeachment
probably restrained Former President Trump
in the last days of his presidency.
So generally I'm feeling pretty good
about this whole affair.
Yes, I wish they had called witnesses
and made the record even more clear
and, frankly, rubbed the
noses of the Republicans
in their own filth for
a little bit longer,
but the record was already 1,000% clear.
This was not a failing
by the House managers
to make a case.
The outcome was already a fait accompli.
Mitch McConnell wouldn't allow trial
while Trump was still in office
and then hid behind his
own political maneuvering
as a reason for why he
couldn't vote for conviction.
And let's face it,
sometimes even futile
gestures are worth doing
because it's the right thing to do.
Seven Republicans voted for conviction
and that's absolutely no small feat
in this hyper-partisan world.
This is not a win for the Trump camp.
They should not be high fiving,
thinking that they did a good job here.
And I think history will be
absolutely clear on this point.
It will show that the acquittal
was a miscarriage of justice,
just like the acquittal of Andrew Johnson
and the acquittal of Donald
Trump the first time around.
But let me know if you
agree with my analysis,
leave your objections in the comments,
and check out this playlist over here
where I talk about all of the legal issues
that happened in the Trump administration
that led up to the impeachment.
So click on this playlist,
or I'll see you in court.